que cambiará para la comunidad lgtb y
más si la propuesta de matrimonio
igualitario pasa en el senado porque es
necesario dar ese paso adelante de las
uniones civiles
lo más importante de este proyecto sin
duda es dejar atrás una legislación y un
estado que valora ciertas familias por
sobre otras en ese sentido la discusión
de este proyecto de ley y el avance y la
aprobación definitiva que esperamos que
ocurra antes de la segunda vuelta es
decir antes del 19 de diciembre
tiene relación precisamente con la
transformación de chile en un país que
respeta la diversidad que no tiene
ciudadanos de primera y de segunda clase
donde todas las familias tienen los
mismos derechos los mismos nombres y por
lo tanto las mismas posibilidades de
crecer y de
desarrollar sus proyectos bueno hacia ya
le quería preguntar porque una de las
grandes luchas de este proyecto es la
adopción homoparental
cómo están las cosas de los padres el
gbc y más no pueden adoptar en conjunto
esta ley mejoraría la situación de los
niños en situación de vulnerabilidad en
el país
efectivamente y además de este proyecto
de ley que permite que las parejas del
mismo sexo puedan iniciar procedimientos
de adopción y esto es sumamente
importante decirlo lo que va a permitir
el proyecto es que las parejas del mismo
sexo puedan ser evaluadas en su
idoneidad y no necesariamente que se les
entregue un niño en adopción verdad
además de este proyecto de ley que
permite esta iniciativa hay otro
proyecto de ley que está tramitándose en
el senado de la república que
precisamente lo que hace es establecer
que todas las familias e incluso las
personas solteras pueden ser evaluadas
en igualdad de condiciones para
encontrar el mejor hogar disponible para
aquellos niños y niñas que han perdido a
su familia y creemos que estos dos
proyectos van en la línea correcta
porque permiten por tanto que más
personas y más familias sin importar su
composición puedan ser evaluadas para
identificar aquellas que
sean un paseo más seguro para estos
niños niñas bueno y finalmente el
proyecto de ley de despenalización del
embarazo hasta las 14 semanas del aborto
se dilató y no se votará hoy de que
depende la decisión y quiero preguntarle
si podría por ejemplo caerse de esta
iniciativa en el caso de que josé
antonio cada ustedes ganará la segunda
vuelta presidencial en chile
bueno en el caso de que susan que no vas
a ganar en la segunda vuelta
presidencial en chile evidentemente
habría una situación bastante compleja
respecto de los derechos humanos de las
personas en el gp y de las mujeres de
las personas migrantes
hay muchas de pueblos originarios por
ciento desde luego habría una situación
bastante compleja respecto de aquellas
comunidades históricamente discriminadas
concluidas y tanto el proyecto de ley de
aborto como también muchas otras normas
que se están discutiendo o que están
escritas no en leyes sino que en
reglamentos o en decretos que pertenecen
al ámbito de funcionamiento de la
presidencia de la república estarían
evidentemente en peligro yo creo que en
ese sentido es importante que las
distintas personas que votan tanto
dentro de chile como en el extranjero
que tiene la ciudadanía identifiquen y
puedan leer ambos proyectos de ley
perdón ambos programas de gobierno para
identificar cuál es el que efectivamente
avanza en el reconocimiento de derechos
de las personas elegibles y de las
mujeres
migrantes de los pueblos originarios y
así tener una sociedad más justa y digna